the defining moment
in a 49-year campaign to clear the names
of the bally murphy dead
families said they sensed their loved
ones with them as a coroner declared
them innocent
i personally felt that our job was
starting to save me
you know i was eight years old when i
lost our job but i have lived my entire
life with a love for him because he was
my big brother
and he looked after me and to this day i
will never
ever ever forget the last few minutes i
had with them
much has changed in this west belfast
neighborhood
but they could never forget the events
of three days in 1971.
the parachute regiment opened fire in
bally murphy
nine men and one woman were killed the
british army labelling them terrorists
but the coroner found all ten completely
innocent
and victims of what she described as a
disproportionate use of force my daddy
is innocent
uh it's so facial that he's innocent
that uh in the history of books he's
innocent
and if my grandkids go to do any
research on madani
he's not a gunman he's the valley murphy
verdict came as the government confirmed
a plan to halt historical prosecutions
here
those who lost relatives say the prime
minister is insulting the memory of the
dead
sherman you bars no one should be above
the law
we will not accept your embassy for
murders
we will every victim should have a right
to
pursue their justice we will never give
up
we will fight on an amnesty would apply
to both veterans and
terrorists devastating for victims of
the ira
and loyalist paramilitary violence too
families need to have
the opportunity of of that of that route
to justice and to close it
um and it seems to me as well you know
it it's almost like it's a dirty little
side deal that's been done between
the british government uh loyalist
paramilitaries and
republican paramilitaries and perhaps
even the irish government as well
i don't know but i tell you one thing
it's not benefiting any victims and
that's that's the truth of the matter
it is agonizing for the families of
those who were shot here
four of them on this same patch of
ground that the inquest findings have
come on the
very day the government decided to draw
a line under the past
because that means no one's ever likely
to be charged in relation to this
incident
or any other before the good friday
agreement
but that's a battle for another day for
now they're just relieved
that their relatives have been
vindicated at last
david blevins sky news in belfast